I'm laureles would I was the moderator
of the session five regional challenges
one solution women it was a very lively
debate lively discussion first reasoning
challenge was talent and education there
was a consensus of that women and girls
are getting education here in the region
not all over but mainly the reason that
there's a gaps of closed and in fact
women are attending college and
postgraduate and greater numbers and men
in some parts of the region the
challenge that was identified however it
was that this investment is not getting
a good return yet that is women are not
yet seen as the as the resource that
they should be seen out there there's
someone under utilized under tapped and
talent is going to be the new capital in
the future that so the greater
realization that women are going to have
to be a much more integral part the
economy much more liberal part of
economic participation we talked a bit
about health and acted in this region
the health gaps between boys and girls
men
its marked in many many countries here
in the region's very optimistic that the
new health caps are closing there's some
very good best practices in the region
that are being used the condition cash
transfers particular money to women
which gets then used for the health of
their children in the welfare of their
their families etc and so very
optimistic and yet still some challenges
gender-based violence is still a
challenge maternal mortality still a
challenge for indigenous women the
access to healthcare isn't as good as it
could be but still some real progress
when the third area was the area of
empowerment economic empowerment and
business performance and here again much
discussion about the fact that women are
underutilized that particularly in this
region there is a very low percentage of
women in toppenish
and I made the comment that I don't
think there's a glass ceiling / women
but I do think that thick layer of men
and that factor sort of comes across by
the number of women CEOs etc and we
moved into Israel leadership and that
the importance of leadership and the
fact that for example Costa Rica has
developed some legislation at fifty
percent of board seats after me with
women and that there are a number of
quota examples of quotas in the region
and that certainly seems to be one way
to hurry history and thereby level talk
about competitiveness natural
competitiveness in the world economic
forum and some excellent research around
this finding that there is a correlation
between close of gender gaps and natural
competitiveness and that this region
could really jump ahead in national
competitiveness by ensuring that women
are tapped as the resource that they are